peut-on porter n'importe quelle tenue à
l'école depuis de nombreuses années la
question fait débat parfois au plus haut
sommet de l'État l'école n'est pas un
lieu comme les autres vous n'avez pas à
l'école comme vous allez à la plage ou
comme vous allez en boîte de nuit les
crop top les jeans déchirés les
mini-jupes ou encore les claquettes
chaussettes font partie des tenues
interdites dans certains établissements
et si dernièrement unicéenne déclare
avoir été exclu de son école c'est pour
avoir porté cette tenue voici ma tenue
inappropriée qui m'a valu une exclusion
et un avertissement car selon ma prof et
l'administration de mon école s'est
provocateur cette nouvelle polémique
intervient alors que certains
adolescents aimeraient bien s'habiller
comme ils le souhaitent notre corps on a
le droit de s'habiller comme on veut
c'est pas nous a bien s'habiller c'est
aux garçons de mieux se tenir alors
exclusion pour tenue inappropriée
comprenez-vous cette décision
ah ça ça fait énormément parler
comprenez vous cette décision Valérie
qui est un petit peu dur de la feuille
ça force d'aller à la Gay Pride non mais
c'est vrai les Chéries comprenez-vous
cette décision non Guillaume non non
mais cette tenue elle a rien de choquant
arrêtez on a tous été au lycée comme ça
TOI
des problèmes peut me contacter sur
Instagram on a tous été au lycée on a
tous été à la fac on a tous vu des
tenues comme ça je pense pas que les
finances moi ce que j'aime pas dans son
message c'est le mot provocateur ça veut
dire quoi c'est qu'en fait il y a des
hommes qui ont des réactions déplacées
c'est de sa faute je trouve que c'est
profondément injuste et je pense que
blague à part elle est victime une sorte
de délit de sale gueule inversé parce
que c'est une belle fille et qu'en fait
les gens qui ont pris cette décision
sont des gens frustrés et aigri qui eux
sont peut-être pas beaux comme elle elle
est belle et ont décidé de la
sanctionner pour ça et franchement il y
a pas de quoi virer quelqu'un pour une
tenue comme ça
Castaldi parlé quand on vous demande la
parole s'il vous plaît Kelly cette jeune
fille elle est clairement en
soutien-gorge je pense que tu deviens
dingue en fait et aveuglé par la beauté
de cette jeune fille justement donc
c'est toi le souci dans cette histoire
le problème parce que là la fille elle
est clairement en soutif là elle a elle
a une tenue d'Instagram et je pense que
il se rendent plus compte de ce qui est
la vie réelle et la vie virtuelle ils
sont en train de tout mélanger et tu vas
pas dans ta vie virtuelle progresser ou
à l'école c'est impossible c'est pas
quelque chose de normal la tenue ou
téléspectateurs qui nous relan s'il vous
plaît une réalisateur si merci voilà
quand on parle d'un sujet il faut
vraiment qu'il a tenu voilà pour que les
gens qui arrivent merci c'est tout
simple voilà donc vraiment pour que les
gens voient de quoi on parle cette jeune
fille dit qu'elle a été exclue ton école
à cause de sa tenue vous Gilles vous
comprenez pas du tout c'est scandaleux
stigmatisation il y a pas d'hyper
sexualisation elle est bien dans sa
tenue elle est bien dans sa vie et on va
la briser en la virant on va la briser
elle apprend que c'est toi qui nous les
brise
sociaux on va briser sa vie le prénom
d'une morale
j'ai déjà brisé je suis déçu par vous
cette fille est déjà brisée en allant à
l'école comme ça
regarde la photo allez on soutien-gorge
avec un truc vert on voit son c'est
c'est descends pour les à l'école ça
c'est comme ça normal c'est c'est normal
elle est couvert elle est couverte d'où
là elle est à poil et à poil derrière la
poêle à l'intérieur
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
discute avec elle on peut discuter et
c'est elle qui choisira en dernier
recettes tout le temps c'est de
l'éducation arrêtez de faire en sorte
que les gamins décident de tout l'école
de quand on y va à quelle heure quand ça
les arrange tu vois ce que là c'est une
période d'éducation une fois qu'ils sont
éduqués après ils font ce qu'ils veulent
c'est comme ça qu'une société fonctionne
ce sont pour l'instant c'est pas décidé
ce sont des gens comme vous ce sont des
gens comme vous qui prive les enfants de
leur liberté de penser et ce sont des
gens comme vous qui vont imposer des
codes à la société alors le laby vous
convient pas on le change ça marche
vraiment vraiment les enfants rois faut
arrêter 2 minutes avec les enfants rois
aussi un moment donné faut que nous
aussi parents on ait la responsabilité
d'éduquer nos enfants les enfants ils
peuvent pas faire tout et n'importe quoi
moi je prends l'exemple de Mathieu si ma
fille je la vois sortir comme ça à
l'école tu vas où là tu vas t'en
soutien-gorge ça m'aurait embêté
maintenant ce que j'aurais préféré que
le proviseur dise la convoc et lui dise
voilà il faut pas venir comme ça à
l'école demain vient autrement et qui ne
la vire pas parce que le fait de la
virer justement on l'en comme ça dans
les médias et on va vous faire un
exemple parce que on se demande si elle
a pas cherché ce truc là parce que
finalement aujourd'hui elle sait très
bien qu'on va réagir et elle allait
communiquer là dessus et ça allait créer
un voilà dans un instant parler d'Adrien
c'est pour l'instant Gilles Verdez vous
vous comprenez pas que cette jeune fille
a été mise dehors de l'école par cette
personne je tombe pas dans le panneau
Géraldine je soutiens cette jeune femme
qui s'est plainte elle-même d'avoir été
viré parce qu'elle est désespérée vous
allez la mettre en dehors du système
vous allez vous allez en faire
une question Gilles parce que c'est bon
non non mais laisse-le parler
maintenant
elle a pas cet âge là d'abord
elle te dit papa je me casse en
sous-titre
avec elle je réponds à vous tiens alors
allez-y honnêtement à son âge là
aujourd'hui sans doute pas mais après je
discute avec elle s'il a envie de se
maquiller c'est l'envie de sa vie
tu fais la langue de bois là tu la
laisses partir ou pas de bêtises
sa mère non moi je serais pas non mais
je voudrais pas mais c'est toi dont on
parle c'est pas sa mère c'est toi je
pense que si elle me dit papa je veux
vraiment cette tenue pour aujourd'hui
j'accepterai ben voilà c'est ça voilà
donc il l'a dit il accepte pas là Daniel
dis excuse-moi mais tu es complètement à
côté c'est d'ailleurs ce que dit fait
tout tous les soirs donc
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
quand tu dis que ça on va briser sa vie
alors d'abord tu es dans l'extrême comme
d'habitude mais au contraire on va lui
rendre un service énorme on va lui
apprendre le reste et il faudrait pas
qu'elle arrive comme ça son premier
entretien donc on va lui apprendre
quelque chose de très utile et il y a
deux trois ans il y a une association
qui avait encouragée des jeunes filles à
aller à l'école avec des tenues
justement inappropriées pour montrer que
c'était des choses des décisions
sexistes on en est là maintenant
malheureusement et ça ça rend service un
petit coup de semence de temps en temps
comme il veut mais c'est insupportable
vous êtes en train de culpabiliser en
string à l'école par exemple justement
il est pas en string elle a un pantalon
elle est passée pas en fait elle est
culpabilisée parce qu'en fait c'est trop
séduisant de fait de montrer son ventre
le fait de voilà et donc vous justifiez
en fait tous les comportements
problématiques il peut y avoir à cause
de cette tenue c'est pas ça
s'il y a des gens qui voient une
connotation sexuelle s'il y a des gens
qui se permettent de l'insulter ou lui
manquer de respect c'est pas de sa faute
c'est de la faute des personnes normal
mais bien sûr que si le discours
féministe le discours féministe en fait
il est en train d'être dévoyé c'est mon
corps ça m'appartient j'ai le droit de
faire n'importe quoi n'importe quoi
je me respecte et personne n'a le droit
de faire quoi que ce soit avec le corps
si j'ai pas envie mais ça ne veut pas
dire non plus d'aller à un premier
travail à un premier boulot en string
d'aller à l'école en fictif
au supermarché au G20 ou au Monoprix à
moitié à poil pour acheter une grève de
raisin
ils ne sont pas la police du costume et
que à chaque adolescente notamment il
faut voir pourquoi elle s'habille comme
ça et moi c'est une jeune femme je lui
dis continuer à vous habiller comme ça
si vous avez été viré de l'école cette
école ne vous mérite pas voilà
bon allez on passe maintenant il est
dangereux quand même
des aberrations mais énormes et surtout
les sujets vous savez quand vous parlez
vous qu'est-ce que tu racontes toi mais
quoi
quel est ton problème avec moi c'est que
tous les deux monopinion sur cette
balise alors dis-lui vas-tu on est en
direct à chaque fois tu dis des bêtises
qui sont énormes on est en train de se
défendre les bêtises défendre
l'éducation défendre certaines valeurs
parce que justement si tu veux que cette
gamine soit un jour heureux dans la vie
il faut qu'elle a un cadre des valeurs
le rôle des parents c'est d'éduquer
c'est pas de pas dire aux enfants fais
ce que tu es ma chérie fais ce que tu
veux quand tu veux parce que c'est comme
ça tu prévois un enfant dans le mur vous
caricaturez
vous incarnez les forces de la réaction
moi j'essaye d'être dans le force du
progrès de comprendre les jeunes
parce que vous avez pas d'arguments donc
c'est un problème pour moi j'ai rien en
face de moi
qui vous couchez vous n'avez plus rien à
dire non vous êtes avec mon petit
banderole comme ça
rentre chez toi tirer dessus dis à ton
enfant qu'il a répondu à l'école
j'essaie de discuter avec une réponse
jamais en fait la vérité si tu donnes
des leçons aux autres mais quand si je
tombe qu'à toi tu réponds déjà
vos questions
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez-y prenez aussi la commande
c'est incroyable
je tombe pas dans cette forme de
caricature que l'on m'impute j'essaye de
défendre des valeurs qui sont
minoritaires très souvent mais qui sont
complètement
vous n'avez pas le monopole de ce qui
est bien et pas bien Mathieu Delormeau
alors voilà même le 6 a fait donc la
retiré
[Applaudissements]